oh man I'm out of shape I think I tore
something if you're wondering why I'm
wearing the same thing is because I'm
shooting this all in one go I need to
make content for you guys and I keep
forgetting that the reason why you're
here is because you want to hear me blog
and I haven't done that it you've been
so upset what have I been busy with my
friend I told you already I was working
on a film baby [ __ ] your mom ooh you
know creepy so recently a subscriber
sent me a very interesting article now
the article stated and there was
multiple articles about this that people
were thoroughly upset at the new Moana
costume if you don't know what Moana is
Moana is the new Disney animated film
that's gonna come out it's a CG animated
film of course featuring the rock and
step out of Polynesian demigod and and
that's all I really know about it so I'm
gonna shut the [ __ ] oh I'm why you ask
because the rock is in it I think I've
watched everything with the rocking it
the run down the run down the one that
looked like the run down but it wasn't a
run down and rock if you're watching
this I know you got a YouTube channel
and I know you need some features on it
all you got to do is hit me up I know
you hit up a lot of other popular
youtubers out there but I really don't
got anything else I don't know but the
problem with this costume circles around
a very familiar phrase that has been the
hot topic of the moment cultural
appropriation now what is so cultural
appropriate idea about this so have you
seen previous for this movie you know
how the demigod looks like he has
tattoos all around and so what they did
with the costume they took that likeness
and they put a skin where you can have
the tattoos on for your kids they want
to be Moana now what a lot of people are
saying on the internet specifically
twitter users are saying that number one
my culture is not a costume nor is my
skin color now how do I feel about it
you ask
I'm not Polynesia so I don't know what
that really feels like a majority of the
tweets that I've read where people were
an uproar and another thing it was all
is that why the [ __ ] every time coach
appropriation comes out it's the white
people are the most angry about it I'm
not saying that's bad it's just [ __ ]
funny to me like have you ever been
kicking in with a bunch of friends and
then all of a sudden you hear somebody
drop the n-bomb and the first person
that's mad is that one way through the
court you do not get to use that word
like what the [ __ ] my main issue with
this is that when something becomes like
a hot topic phrase people tend to
overuse it and the problem with
overusing afraid that does have a lot of
meaning behind it is that you tend to
cry wolf too much so when you cry wolf
so odd then we all know about that story
people stopped to care because they
don't know whether it's genuine or
disingenuous now for this if Polynesian
people out there are offended by this
then you have every right to go ahead
and no speak out about how you feel with
it but to put it on the flip side of
things the character in the movie is a
Polynesian character he has tattoos so
kids are gonna want to be the Polynesian
demigod that he's playing and of course
it's going to be this weird blurred line
with it because the movie is all about
Polynesian culture it's a cultural thing
and it just kind of sucks that it
coincides with going with the costume
Disney maybe you should thought about it
a little more through can I'm getting
sick and tired of Disney culturally
appropriate a lot of things number one
I'm gonna speak up for those [ __ ]
mermaids
how did mermaids don't have seashell
tittays wait was she uh was she of eight
oh my god no no no no no get me do you
that's not the right movie hi God
anything but what do you guys think
cultural appropriation a boo [ __ ] whoo
you know creepy but the issue around the
Moana costume once again surfaces
circles around the issue of what we call
cultural of LVH appropriation I [ __ ]
the appropriation look at the shadow
looks like there's a dick on my teeth
but the problem with this costume circle
Sparkle but I have heard a few tweets
were a couple of Polynesian people were
a bit but I have read a few T's world
I said deeds